¿Crees que la Unión Europea está haciendo 1 buen trabajo?
1 difusión de información para los jóvenes.
Yo creo que hay mucha queja
de que la Unión Europea es algo muy lejano
y a mí me pasa mucho en España.
Muchas veces estoy en España y la gente me dice,
la gente joven
es que hay en Europa
y yo siempre les digo sí. Pero si estamos en Europa
ya, estés en Murcia,
estés en Palma,
estés en Canarias,
estés en Galicia, estás en Europa.
Y es cierto que Tal vez la información no llega,
pero quien quiere leerla la lee porque estar está aquí.
es cierto que yo creo que con los 2º de comunicación
hay que hacer otro trabajo.
Pero también te digo lo,
lo que los jóvenes de hoy
saben de la Unión Europea
es 20 veces más que los de hace 20 años
y la tendencia es Clara
en que a veces hay más información,
hay más interés y la gente cada vez es más paciente
de todo lo que hace la Unión Europea por ellos